hey everyone
welcome
i am super
excited
the subject of fasting
has been something that has absolutely
captivated me
for several years
and i've been doing my best
to synthesize
and distill all of the core components
of fasting
and this is the first
synthesis and distillation on the topic
and we have plans to
create a really powerful documentary on
the subject
one that has even more animation
and time and effort and art
and story
in it that communicates the profundity
of fasting
even more efficiently
across the internet into the world
because we
have to wake up as a planet to fasting
specifically in
2020 in the middle of the year
i found herbert shelton
who's one of the greatest
synthesis and distillers on the subject
of fasting that i've
ever found in my life and i read so
much of his distillation literature on
fasting and i pieced
together the most profound concepts in
with also the modern people like alan
goldhammer
who's had 20 000 patients go through his
true north health center that he's been
founding and directing for the last 37
years
where they do things like a
monitored 10-day water fast
with health professionals
and they've had absolutely incredible
results
and they're in the process of submitting
more and more scientific literature
on the health benefits of fasting
and naturopathy in general
which is such an important critical
indigenous
concept that modernity needs to embed
at a deeper level in its heart generally
means the upkeep
of youthful health by diet
exercise sleep massage air
sun water fasting
so using the natural
remedies to maintain youthful health
so these two have been two of my most
massive
influences on the subject
and in general you can think of fasting
as going for a period of time
without something
and in this case we'll be talking a lot
about fasting
from food
and the incredible health benefits that
that has
but in modernity we also hear a lot
about
people that are choosing to fast from
technology and doing these digital
detoxes for periods of time
which we've touched on quite a bit in
our other content
to simply take a day without
speaking to take a day without
technology
and to nature bathe for that day
and to just relax and just to see what
happens
what incredible intuitive lightning
bolts and experiences unfold for you
and there's other things that people are
fasting from as well
and so we can think about the word as
again
going for a period of time without
something
fasting all right
so i'm so pumped for this
oh my gosh it's been such a while
for me on synthesizing
and distilling the core concepts in this
field
that i just loved so much
on both a scientific and a spiritual
level
and to be doing this first stream on the
subject and to be preparing
all of this other downstream content on
it is so
meaningful to me because it eradicates
so many of the perverse incentives
and it uplifts so many of the nature
driven remedies to maximize our health
and well-being
and it teaches us how to delay our
gratification and
there's so much more that we're going to
get into here in a bit
as you can tell quite passionate about
the subject
all right therapeutic slash hygienic
fasting
it's been called the fasting cure
instinct
the rest cure fasting is the greatest
remedy fasting is the most efficient
means
for correcting any disease
i've been on a record saying that
fasting is a near panacea
so you'll
solve almost any
major health issue
that you have at the most
root level so not at the symptoms
downstream but
upstream at the most root level through
fasting
and we'll get to that here more in
detail
i love these three words for fasting
organic house cleaning
it's perfect organic house cleaning
how often have you cleaned your house of
your body
your temple of your body how often have
you cleaned it
how often have you given the organs
and the gastrointestinal tract just
a break for one day
or are you so addicted to the
neurochemical storms that you get from
eating food
that you can't even undergo that tiny
reset process for your body that organic
house cleaning
how to treat the sick without medicine
a fast is to the organs of the body what
a night of
restful repose is to the tired laborer
upton sinclair the great thing about the
fast
is that it sets you a new standard of
health
plutarch instead of using medicine
rather fast a day
to become
sovereign enough to
gain back your ability to delay your
gratification to discipline yourself
enough to reject
the neurochemical storms and the
short-term gratification of
shoving food into your mouth in order to
try and heal your body through this
organic house cleaning
is so profound and so paramount for
civilization
to have land in their hearts
wise people falling into any ailment
take a bath go to bed and fast
leaving nature to do her own
work of cure and not
hindering her beneficent
operations
fasting is not only a therapeutic agent
of the highest degree
possible but also deserves to be taught
worldwide
so crucial
fasting equals physiological
rest and rejuvenation fasting
equals physiological rest and
rejuvenation
one gives the vital organs a complete
rest two
stops the intake of foods emptying and
rejuvenating the gi
tract gastrointestinal tract
three promotes elimination of diseased
tissue and cellular components four
restores youthful condition and function
throughout the body
five clears and strengthens the mind
fitness increases literally
your biological fitness increases
because you're delaying your
gratification for this organic house
cleaning
so that you can
eradicate the diseased components from
your cells
so that you can give your gi tract and
organs a break
so that you can restore the general
youthful condition
for the temple that is your body
it's like being in the kitchen
and
using the appliance
in the kitchen non-stop like the stove
imagine just having the stove on
all the time all the time you're just
snacking imagine
snacking snacking all day long every day
it'd be like having the stove on from
when you wake up
until when you go to sleep every single
day
that'd be insane you're never giving
your stove a break
you're never giving your body your
vehicle
a break
it needs to be fine-tuned with that
physiological rest and rejuvenation
it's really the fine-tuning of it just
like we fine-tune
our airplanes that have
hundreds of sensors on them we should
fine-tune our bodies as well with these
sensors
that give us insight into our stream of
biometrics
that we can then have incredible
artificial intelligence
run computations on to maximize our
youthful
rejuvenative capacities to feel like 18
year olds
for much longer periods of time
than to be having all of these health
ailments at young
ages
fasting is one of the most common
phenomena in nature
second only to feeding and reproduction
it is estimated that fasting for the
alleviation of human suffering
has been practiced uninterruptedly for
10 000 years
we have made a fetish of eating and have
developed a ridiculous fear of going
without food
even for a day
so true we have this lineage of
millennia
of knowing to stop
putting fuel into our bodies because we
already have so many reserves in
fat and especially
when we have an ailment happening in our
body
that we can more efficiently call upon
our immune system call upon the
eradication of those diseased components
by simply allowing our organic house
cleaning to naturally happen
without shoving more and more especially
high sos salt oil sugar food into our
body
give our body the natural ability to
decrease the inflammation
give our body the natural ability to
heal the strained muscles and the
strained
especially intracellular components
misfolded proteins dysfunctional
mitochondria
we'll get into that in a bit we've made
a complete
fetish out of eating three times a day
as a culture complete fetish oh my gosh
i'm going to die if i don't eat
it's like dude you just ate yesterday
and you're whining
you're not starving learn how to go
a day without food discipline yourself
there's a process of neuro adaptation
that happens that then
enables you to go
longer in longer periods of time without
needing to eat food
enabling you to do the organic house
cleaning
culture beats the drum of consume
consume consume consume consume
non-stop because you're a better
component of the economic machinery
when you're consuming consuming
consuming consuming
but when you say nope i'm not going to
consume
and you fast there's perverse incentives
in the economic machinery we'll talk
about those in a bit
take the path that's not wandered
you have 99 of civilization that's
funneling into this
this ridiculousness of eating every
single day
and sometimes even eating three meals a
day
or snacking throughout the whole day
walk the path that's not
wandered and explore what it's like to
be in that one percent or so
that's actually been on a three-day fast
and you can start with low numbers like
that
because those are low numbers and those
are quite
easy to get to with just a little bit of
discipline
and there are so many other benefits
that happen
digestion and assimilation of food are
attacks
on the vital powers of the organism and
increase
the work of the stomach liver intestines
heart lungs kidneys glands etc
the more food eaten the more work these
already overworked organs are called
upon to perform
just think about it at a level of basic
physiology
basic biological processes
it would be ridiculous to think that
when i put
food inside of my body that it's not
going to take
an amount of biological process and
physiology
in order for the gastric acids to break
down the food
and for the stomach to then undergo the
further digestive process
that then undergoes entering into the
small intestine and the large intestine
and the absorption of that
of the nutrients that
process itself is
taxing on the body
it would be ludicrous to think that
it doesn't tax the body and every single
one of us experientially knows it too
where we are in flow
and as soon as we eat something
that we can literally tell that our body
is dedicating
processing capacities to the digestive
tract
of our body rather than what we were
doing in the flow state before
you can feel the reallocation of bodily
resources to the digestive tract
when you eat something you can literally
feel it but you have to become
sensitive enough to feel it you have to
become subtle enough to feel it
if you've never been quiet enough to
even feel your own
heartbeat
or to simply be silent enough
to where you can hear the digestion
happening inside of your body very
clearly
and the nutrients being moved to the
different parts of your body
then you haven't gotten to a level of
subtlety
and sensitivity yet to where you can
actually
navigate these oceans of experience
that are so fascinating
the sensitivity and the subtlety of
being able to navigate this
enables a lot more downstream fruits
as well it enables you to be more like a
jedi
across work across family across
friends across everything
that you do
sick animals refuse all food
serious sickness prompts all animals to
fast
dogs horses cows animals
fasting 10 20 30 plus days
during internal injury slash broken
bones
trees even store food in their roots
like
bears store fat
there's so many recorded examples of
animals that when they have these severe
injuries that they go on these prolonged
fasts and that it enables them to heal
more efficiently
yet the human animal
struggles with delaying its
gratification
until suffering which is the drill
sergeant for awakening
comes at such a intense
level to where the
delayed gratification is forced upon the
human animal
because it knows that if it takes the
instant gratification
that it will have so much pain and so
much suffering
that it won't even be worth it then it
begins delaying its gratification
suffering is that drill sergeant for
awakening
and it's crazy because even trees
store food in their roots this was
fascinating
learning about this because when we
think about it during the winter
time especially in areas where it snows
where the tree actually has the process
of shedding its
leaves that the tree
for those three months or six months or
however long it is
during the winter depending on where it
is geographically
undergoes a process of hibernation in a
sense and very similarly like the bear
does
it undergoes that process of hibernation
and so we have so much fat we have so
many nutrients
located here inside of our bodies that
we can draw
upon for prolonged periods of fasting
and that's why you'll see like in the
thumbnail
and like in so many of the other
videos that are on the internet people
have been going
on 10 20 30 day 40 day
fasts and they're losing like a pound a
day
sometimes even two pounds per day so
people are in a month losing sometimes
30 or 50
pounds just from doing water only
fasting
and this is especially important when
people have metabolic syndrome when they
have high blood pressure
high blood sugar when they're obese
because people can just
shed weight just like that
and become much healthier the first two
days of the fast
are usually the hardest do one
to the persistence of the demand for
food
and two to the sudden withdrawal of the
accustomed stimulation
the bodily sensations of fasting are in
many cases
more pleasant than the bodily sensations
of
feasting we all know this this is a very
common
phenomena is that when you sit
and eat if you're doing other things
while you eat again it's the allocation
of basic biological processing and
physiology
that if you're not in the process of
meditating or mindful about literally
the food you're going to taste it less
because if you're trying to do something
like watch something
or do something while you're eating
you're going to notice that you're
tasting your food
less and less while you're consuming
that other content
so while you eat be very mindful of
meditative
don't distract yourself with other
things just pay attention to the taste
of the food and how beautiful that is
and then you won't accidentally bite
your gums
or bite your inside of your cheek or
bite your tongue or have one of those
chips or whatever just snap up into your
gums because you're much more mindful
of how you're eating
and
that process is
also more
beautiful for the actual recognition
of when the taste of the food becomes
null so we've experienced this where
when you eat about
you know 50 of the portion that you were
eating
you recognize that after that 50 you
don't even taste
the food as much as you did at the first
part that's your taste buds acclimating
and so it's
almost better to either have a variety
of different foods
so that you can
switch between the different dimensions
of taste
that you have
or to take the portion size of that one
big meal and just literally chop it in
half
and you get these sensations that come
from
feasting that are like oh the
first you know third or half of the meal
you're like oh this is so good it's so
good
and then the second half you're just
like i barely can even taste this
uh i feel like a slob
and now i have this big
food baby that's happening that is
making me
more lethargic and idle and less
driven and motivated to achieve the
goals that i had
intended to do today
versus when you get the bodily
sensations of fasting once you get over
these
ghrelin spikes which we'll talk about
the hunger hormone
you become more and more especially if
you have
aches and pains especially if you're
suffering
those aches and pains disappear more and
more as you get into a prolonged fast
and it begins feeling better and better
a man's foes shall be they of his own
household
even missing one meal is often enough to
cause a family alarm that results in a
near panic
it is wise therefore to get away from
family
and friends when undertaking a fast
drop all fear
the fear-mongering especially by
family and by ignorance
is
so overwhelmingly fearful on the person
that is undergoing the process
of fasting for a day or two or three
that it triggers so many people to not
do it
because their ignorant family or friends
are saying don't do it
don't not eat for one day you're going
to die
it's the most ignorant dumb
thing that i've ever heard in my life
it's so stupid
it's so ignorant just
distance yourself from your ignorant
family and friends
that don't know jack [ __ ] about basic
biology and basic
physiology and basic history
of the species
and and really basic healthcare 101
fasting is that but it's totally not
treated that way
and distance yourself from them and
undergo your fast
and then after the period of three days
when you're like wow i feel great
i feel like the organic house cleaning
took in process
i feel like my aches and pains went away
i feel like my sensory acuity
increased all that type of stuff
then let them know
and remember that there's so many
perverse incentives that we're going to
get to here in a moment
that are trying to keep people ignorant
of
fasting because of all of the benefits
of
it
in all of the ways that you will not
contribute to the economic machinery
as you do a free process of fasting
drop all fear
as lao tzu said fear is the greatest
illusion
we're brainwashed and hypnotized by
culture for millennia to
recognize ourselves as finite
rather than be able to expand ourselves
to infinity
expand ourselves to eternity which is
our true nature
this is just one expression of
the infinite or the eternal
but again that cultural hypnosis
has made it so that people
think that they're finite
that this is it just this one expression
is it
there's there's nothing before this
there's not going to be anything after
this
this is just it it's the most stupid
thinking ever and that's why even people
like sirajo penrose who won the nobel
prize
in physics in 2020 has a cyclic
cosmological
theory it's becoming more and more
mainstream
the oroboros the snake eating its tail
that we are the infinite expressing
itself
through these realities
and we've been doing it and we're gonna
keep doing it and that's our true nature
also if you haven't figured out about
this
trick yet especially if you use the
computer a lot
this is a great trick just take the
tennis ball
and rub it between your palms you can
also do this
and rub it right there
for your thumbs especially
from all the computer use it's crucial
and you can take it
and you can also
get into your your trapezoids
and get into your lats
get into your triceps
your forearms
it's a massive life hack
and then you can also put it under your
foot put it under your foot
and stand and roll the bottom of your
foot on it
feels amazing and that's what's been
known by
these more indigenous practices are
these
acupuncture points
very lost on modernity things like the
traditional
indigenous naturopathy
fasting
a lot of life
just boils down to the marshmallow
experiment
walter michelle has been so profoundly
influential on
modernity because this is the most
simple
way to understand it either you're going
to go for the
instant gratification on
all of these bifurcations in your tree
of possibility that exists throughout
your day
and life either you're going to go for
that instant gratification
of taking the one marshmallow and
shoving it down into your throat
or you're going to delay your
gratification
and that's why there's the dis ease that
happens from the instant gratification
again just shoving food non-stop into
your body
or sitting there and just scrolling
mindlessly
on the internet versus when you
delay your gratification delay your
gratification you fast for a day
you don't go on social media for a day
instead you go out and you bathe in the
sun
and you stretch in the sun and you
read the book that you've been
ignoring for months if not years to
actually read
with the highlighter and enjoy the
process of consuming content
that way which has a completely
different
effect on the
neurophysiology
than does a 15 second
video where you're actually retaining
those core concepts
and so the vast majority of life boils
down to
having the ease from
delaying your gratification
delaying your gratification is going to
produce more ease and instant
gratification is going to produce more
dis-ease it's really that simple
and delaying gratification is a near
panacea
delay your gratification keep delaying
your gratification
keep doing it don't open up the
pornography and masturbate
don't eat the second piece of pizza
or of chocolate cake
recognize more and more that when you
delay your gratification they're going
to
achieve
better and better long-term success
and prosperity and happiness and peace
and abundance
and just anti-fragile youthful
rejuvenative moment-to-moment
life and longevity
this is another critical part of this
this was leo tolstoy who found a
fascinating connection between gluttony
and idleness
and you can think about this at the
geoeconomic level
so you look at the united states and
you're like holy cow what a powerhouse
during the 20th century
just rose up to the number one position
economically
and just have so much prosperity and
abundance and then what happens
you have high fructose corn syrup you
have
sos salt oil sugar
you have the information
technology overload as well
unable to parse for signal in all of the
noise
and so what you have is you have
gluttony
you have more and more of the instant
gratification
culture where now you can
have any of the delivery applications
just bring you any saturated salt
oil sugar foods to your
home in the click of a button and
because of that gluttony now
we are becoming idle lethargic
so we now have for the last couple of
decades in the united states
experienced lethargy and idleness
and that's a big reason why we're not as
interested
in going to the low-hanging fruits
of the orchards of technology and
innovation and creativity
and art and spirituality and just
actualizing all of that potential
because instead
we have these these food babies we're in
these food
comas we're in these information comas
where it feels like there's that that
lump
of damp sawdust that is just chilling
inside
of our gi tract or where we just have
absolutely no
cognitive drive whatsoever to go and
achieve
those low hanging fruit that then
maximize the growth of the economic pie
in the united states
so you can even take this to a
geoeconomic level as well
so
the more that a country becomes wise
the more that it recognizes to not over
indulge in instant gratification and
gluttony
and instead to delay its gratification
and continue the achievement
of the low-hanging fruits in the
orchards
that then continue growing the pie
that's why when you look at
the redalio projection for the united
states you see it on its
downward portion of the parabola
and that the rise of the
decentralization technologies and
cryptocurrencies
and the benevolent distribution
of the fruits of artificial general
intelligence
and other emerging markets like
entheogens and cannabis and hemp
psychedelics is going to be really
important for us to be able to rise
from that back upwards in a growing
pie but we need to be
wise and recognize that geoeconomically
that
instant gratification is our biggest
cancer
geopolitically instant gratification is
our biggest
cancer delay
your gratification more and more
and you'll recognize that the pie will
increase
more and more for everybody
a full stomach does not like to think
our national drug addictions and our
almost
universal overeating tend to reduce
mental abilities mental clarity to
execute
diminishes excess is fatal
to healthy action and i'm going to bring
this up again later
but that's why one of the three
most profound delphic maxims
from greece from 2000 plus years ago
are nothing in excess
along with know thyself and surety
brings ruin
nothing in excess
and gluttony is everything in excess
gluttony is give me more of that salt
oil and sugar
more and more of that give me more and
more of the
information technology stimulation
of completely vapid meaningless
noise-filled content
saturation more and more saturation
more and more like a zombie scrolling
more and more like a zombie eating
without even tasting
reset do the organic house cleaning
move more and more on the bifurcations
towards the delayed gratification
all right on a perspective of
industrialization
we are addicted to salt oil sugar sos
because of the neurochemical storms
the neurochemical storms dopamine
serotonin
we adore the
pleasure of instant gratification
we've become a slave to it and that
makes us
sedated makes us sedated it makes us
sedentary it makes us lazy
lethargic it drives more pathology
disease in our bodies
and so we withdraw ourselves from this
accustomed stimulation
and move towards the delayed
gratification
where we deprive ourselves of that
instant gratification of the
neurochemical storms of dopamine
serotonin these other neuromodulators
and the a custom stimulation has become
so
embedded within the social fabric we
don't even recognize what we're talking
about we're talking about
coffee tea chocolate cacao
alcohol tobacco cannabis meat
pepper spices salt oil
sugar etc
as though we are such a zombie
that we don't even recognize our over
indulgence in these
accustom stimulates anymore
fast from these stimulants for a day
also talking is a stimulant
zip silence
for one day technology is a stimulant
close it for one day
go out in the sun stretch your body
sunbathe read a book
go and be playful and joyful and
childlike with your friends
if you want to be silent with them as
well
bring some bubbles to the park
bring a little frisbee move your body
sitting there and going like this like a
zombie
which we've all fallen into the trap of
brings so little value and meaning
compared to the delayed gratification
compared to the organic house cleaning
we now have more obese humans than
starving
on the planet it's [ __ ] crazy
somewhere over a billion
or so and now there's
less than a billion starving
across the planet it's crazy
multinational corporations and lifelong
prescriptions
perverse incentives versus holistic
biology
it's like the unconditional love
of mom of that holistic
mother nature versus the
extractive incentives
of the multinational corporations and
big pharma
that treat you just like a slave to
their salt oil sugar
to their pharmaceutical lifelong
prescriptions
because you're worth more to them as a
slave
than you are as an enlightened being
that recognizes those perverse
incentives and that doesn't
fall to the manipulation
and eventually we'll architect the
social fabric and incentives to make the
enlightened
being prioritized so there's no
perverse incentives that exist like that
so that it feels like the unconditional
love is everywhere
on on an enlightened civilizational
level
an awakened and prosperous civilization
go look at the video footage from 1900
to 1950 when everyone was super thin
there are more and more of these
channels popping up on the internet
where you can see these videos that were
taken
from a hundred years ago and
that they have done a process of using
artificial intelligence to upscale these
videos
and you can see in these videos
where people are still using horses
on the streets cars are just emerging
and people are
skinny fatness is not a thing
obesity is not a thing
everyone is just ridiculously skinny
you look at geoeconomic gluttony
geoeconomic gluttony
creating all of the idleness in
all of the pathology from just
the obsession with instant gratification
spirituality knew about nature therapy
then science began showing the decrease
in cortisol levels
spirituality knows about fasting now
science is catching up and showing the
health benefits
it's ridiculous you look at
what spirituality has been promulgating
for thousands of years which is to just
go out in nature bathe
and then you have the
scientific skepticism that's like oh
there's no
evidence that that's actually helpful
and then
it's so stupid because you can literally
have
the feeling at a physiological level of
how good it feels for that day to go
nature bathe
compared to just shoving salt oil
sugar down your throat and just being
sedentary all day
and then finally science is like okay
sure there's a decrease in cortisol
levels the stress hormone when you go
out in nature bathe it's like no [ __ ]
and same thing today with fasting
spirituality for
millennia thousands of years has been
promulgating the idea of fasting
being super critical and important
delaying your gratification
and you have all of this bs online
from the scientific skeptic community
about
oh well we're not quite sure yet about
fasting it's like no we're [ __ ] sure
and we've been
sure for millennia
you're not going to die from not eating
for a day you're not going to have
adverse reactions
from not eating for a day
the incentives of the economic machinery
are perverse
but it's good because now science is
rising up to the challenge and is
proving things
at even the intracellular level with
things like
autophagy which we'll get into of the
self
eating of the diseased components
and other things like measuring ketosis
and beta hydroxybutyric and there's a
lot of
other really great scientific components
that are being analyzed now
which are fantastic the decreases in
the metabolic syndrome and
thank goodness for places like true
north and alan goldhamer and the whole
team there for continuing the process
over decades
even though the it's a very much like
the gated institutional narrative
like eric weinstein says you have the
disc
this distributed idea suppression
complex that
absolutely refuses to allow
fasting to rise up in the mainstream
media narrative
but it's good signs of spirituality are
synthesizing and ascending together now
which is exciting
the world in many ways is made to make
us
fat sick and miserable usa
has five percent of the world's
population and eighty percent
of opiate use
ninety five percent of attention deficit
drug use
against such perverse incentives you
don't
need that pharmaceutical nonsense
you need discipline and you need
natural remedies and
delayed gratification and incentives
to habituate yourself
to delaying gratification
and there are so many other incredible
remedies
on the level of nature with cannabinoids
and with entheogens that exist that just
take a
complete just slap
opiates out of the picture but you have
again the perverse incentives
of things like purdue pharma and the
sackler family and what happened with
the opiate epidemic
and it's just gonna continue to be
nonsense until the incentives are
fixed at the level of the social fabric
where
capitalism does not produce these
externalities that then go downstream
to destroy families and to destroy
the long-term potential
due to the instant gratification of a
select
few cancerous
cells that don't know any better because
they're just self-dealing
and in this analogy the cancer cells are
like the sackler family self-dealing
purdue pharma self-dealing
and so that's what capitalism 2.0 is the
hyper incentivization of creativity
but also the hyper socialization of
making the social fabric
more robust more anti-fragile
meeting the basic needs of more people
worldwide and
constantly fueling that process
inclusive stakeholding and perverse
incentives
again fasting is completely free
zero dollar spent and money saved
time saved from shopping buying food
storing it cooking it eating cleaning
digestion saving somewhere between one
to three hours per day
if you're eating three quick meals
you might save an hour but if you're
really taking your time
with food every single day you're
saving three hours that day
the medical and food industrial complex
doctors
pharma multinational food companies the
economy doesn't want you to know about
fasting
you're worth more to the economy buying
food
visiting doctors taking pharma then
fasting
the new economic markers have to be
prioritized for well-being prosperity
and inclusive equity
we talk about this a lot on our show
thanks to especially jun yoon passing
along inclusive stakeholding
the idea that the doctor should have an
inclusive stake
in the patient's life outcome rather
than have an inclusive stake in the
pharmaceutical company
doesn't that sound stupid the doctor
having a stake in the pharmaceutical
company
is the dumbest thing i've ever heard
because there's going to be perverse
incentives for them to prescribe the
pharmaceuticals to the patient when
they're not even needed
now if the doctor on the smart contract
leveraging great technologies like
ethereum has a
token invested interest
in their patients life outcome
then the doctor is going to recognize
that actually i should be prescribing
more naturopathy
for my patient and less pharmaceuticals
and less perverse incentives
so the incentives have to be aligned
there has to be goal congruence
between the doctor and the patient or
between the teacher
and the student or between the
government and its citizens
at a deeper level so that you don't have
this
kleptocracy that is siphoning
away the
well-being and prosperity of the masses
of a country
for just the benefit of a select few
again all that goal congruence can be
built into the social contract
into the social fabric itself especially
given
the smart contracts and tokenomics that
are blossoming in the decentralization
and cryptocurrency
infrastructures and mechanism design
that's being promulgated today
so really invest hard into that space
for inclusive stakeholding and equity
there's all these different types you
have intermittent fasting where you have
the short
daily feeding windows example from 12 to
8 pm
so that's usually called 16 off 8 on
so 16 hours of the day you're not eating
and then eight hours of the day you're
eating something like that
and this is typically done from
you know the window of about noon to 8
pm
people usually skipping breakfast and
they only have their first little
lunch salad sandwich whatever
around noon and then maybe they wait
until six o'clock and they have dinner
until 7 30 or whatever
and so
the idea of being able to restrict
yourself to not eat
a 1 am snack or to not eat
right when you get up at 8 a.m to at
least have that discipline is a great
first step to restrict your feeding
window
and science is proving that intermittent
fasting is fantastic of course because
you can't just keep
shoving food into your body all day long
you're not made for that
not made for all this gluttony and
instant gratification
and then there's omad which is one meal
a day so this is usually people that
fast
all the way up until six o'clock or
seven or eight o'clock
p.m and then they have their one meal
and it's really important to not overeat
at that meal for example i do a lot of
omad
and when i get to that six seven eight
o'clock meal
i have to be very aware
and not doing other activities while i
eat
because then i only eat maybe 60 or 70
percent
capacity which is great you want to eat
like harahachi buu you want to eat until
you're about 80
full which we'll get to that in a bit as
well
and to have that conscious eating
process
where you're not distracted it really
helps you
and to space it out over maybe an hour
or something like that
also helps a lot in the process
and there's alternate day fasting eating
every other day
there's extended fasting when you
undergo a 3
5 7 10 20 day fast
there's oma one meal a week
which was fascinating i i did that as
well recently
and it was pretty cool
and it was
really beneficial for some of my back
problems which i'll
explain more in detail in a bit
and it's interesting to explore all of
the different microbiomes and body types
and the way that things like omad and
oma and extended fasting and
intermittent fasting affect people
because people do have
different and unique microbiomes and
just
biological compositions in general
so that's why there's usually not
a specific panacea like everybody should
eat
spinach or everybody should eat
blueberries or whatever
and fasting might be the closest thing
we have to a panacea
that works for everybody or nearly
everybody
for nearly all reasons as well
for health ailments hunger
makes people healthy and the hawthorn
effect as well
observation and accountability so
when you have the observer or somebody
holding you accountable
you're much more likely to not overeat
to over indulge
when you're at the event you're much
more likely to maybe only eat one
cookie rather than if you're at home
with a pack of cookies you'll probably
eat
five of them because there's nobody
observing you and nobody to hold you
accountable
ketosis critical part of this
so what happens when you fast is you
begin burning
fat instead of glucose you deplete your
glycogen stores in about 24 hours and
you enter into
ketosis and you have to get over things
like ghrelin
which is the hunger hormone so ghrelin
secretes every couple hours for a short
time window
and you have to neuro adapt to get
beyond those ghrelin spikes
where you feel
in the in the stomach
where it's you're being driven to
do the short term gratification and eat
but to neuro adapt to be able to get
over those windows
where it spikes and continue
extending your ketosis and fast
you'll get even more exciting
bodily sensations that occur from the
fast rather than feast
so again your liver is burning the fat
for energy
undergoing gluconeogenesis undergoing
cell autophagy
the largest draft upon the body stores
during a fast is made upon the fat
there's a higher concentration of atp
adenosine triphosphate molecular energy
from the burning of fat rather than the
burning of glucose
ketogenic dieting has become very
popular
again it's a very high fat and low carb
diet higher beta hydroxybutyrate bhb
blood ketones this improves
memory and avoids obesity in mice
bhb is synthesized in the liver via the
metabolism of fatty acids
bhp is the most abundant of the three
ketone bodies created by the liver
accounting
78 of ketones
bhb inhibits hca2 gpcr
the g protein couple receptor for
lipolysis
atherosclerosis inducing vasodilation
and mediates nice and induced flushing
bhb also increases brain derived
neurotrophic factor
bdnf promoting nerve growth
bhb improves your body's accessibility
to genes
therefore your cell's ability to
synthesize proteins
stays strong improvements in metabolic
health
longevity resistance to oxidative stress
for the brain bhb causes reduction in
free radicals decreases neural
inflammation
and improves cognition in patients with
dementia
so many benefits fasting favorably
alters the gut microbiome
organs shrink down during fasting and
then regrow after feeding
fasting stresses healthy cells so they
increase their stress response pathways
including heat shock proteins
antioxidant production
and anti-inflammation abilities
ketogenic diet
improves symptoms in people with
autoimmune disease
again ketosis and ketogenic dieting
are becoming more and more popular in
mainstream culture
because the science is finally catching
up to the spirituality around
fasting
and that's why the chinese have begu
which means grain avoidance which we'll
get to later
as well where you have to understand
that
the whole grain brain phenomenon is
really recent about 10 000 or so years
of evolution and
for the overwhelming ingestion of
carbohydrates and also
the recognition that
a more
caveman style diet a more
high fat style diet because you can also
get that from your avocados and nuts and
so many other things
but that
is in many ways
more true to our evolutionary nature
but it is also important to recognize
that each
microbiome is different that there are
going to be people
that are more able to eat
cheese like the italians
you know and there's gonna be other
people that are less likely
to be able to eat cheese like the
okinawans
and their ability to
[Music]
have higher mercury levels from fish
maybe higher and that's why the study of
the blue zones is really important which
we'll talk about later as well
and also the uniqueness of every single
one of our blueprints
of our microbiome it's like a
fingerprint
for each of us inside as well at the
level of the microbiome
and just the biological composition and
what
foods are most optimal for our
moment-to-moment
living and longevity
more critical science here the
biomarkers of exercise are similar
with the biomarkers of fasting so both
exercise and fasting reverse the
consequences of dietary excess
rats with exercise wheels don't get
neurodegeneration
bdnf brain-derived neurotrophic factor
goes
up with fasting like it does with
exercise and intellectual stimulation
bdnf encourages the survival of neurons
growth and differentiation of new
neurons and synapses
neurogenesis learning memory
and higher thinking so bdnf
is a critical part of this as well just
like
bhb is and you're going to have those
two
be massive key insights in
the further scientific discovery of the
benefits of
fasting
and this is huge with the longevity
movement as well there is a huge market
for healthy people to stay healthy
fasting makes aches and pains disappear
the body is able to
heal itself by day four or day five
and for many people it ends up being the
first time in 10 years
the pain in their lower back goes away
and
for example for me i've went on these
five day fast that have healed my near
paralysis back pain
so both in
the summer of 2020 i had near paralysis
back pain
and i fasted for five days and i felt
incredible
water only and same thing here recently
in january as well
that in 2021 that
i had this near paralysis back pain
again and i fasted for five days
water only and boom my pain was like a
eight out of ten it was horrible back
pain
barely able to walk and
that dropped by day five to like two out
of ten
back pain from just the water only
fasting
and you'll have so many people that
don't know about
the benefits of fasting they don't know
and so what they do is they
continue eating three meals a day of
high salt oil sugar
they don't go out in to sunbathe in
nature therapy
they don't exercise or move their bodies
just keep laying down
and they wonder why the disease
continues
stop putting food in your body you have
plenty of fat
to burn for energy you'll live and
you'll give your body that reset to
tackle all of that inflammation and
disease
naturally do the organic house cleaning
and also go
and see on day one or day two of the
fast go and see a chiropractor go and
see
a masseuse for an hour take good care of
the vehicle
and what you'll recognize is that after
you get that adjustment to that massage
that go to bed that night also not
eating and by that second or third
day of fasting you're really gonna feel
a lot
better it's critical
that's why we're so passionate about
this because we know
that much of your suffering can be
tackled by the simple delayed
gratification to fasting
so learn how to shut up for 10 straight
days
we talk about that a lot on the show the
ability to sit silently at
meditation retreats like vipassana which
i've done four times and i've absolutely
adored
where there's no talking there's no
technology there's no eye contact for 10
straight days
and if you learn how to even just shut
up for one day let alone 10
and just not talk you'll notice a lot of
profound things happen
a lot of beautiful intuitive insights
happen also no technology as well
refrain
and same thing learn how to fast for 10
straight days
so i have yet to do a 10 straight
day fast i'm planning on it and i'm
really excited for it
and i've done many five day fasts and
i've done many three day fasts
and they're awesome and i adore them
and it'll be exciting to see what
happens on the
10 day and also just in general to
popularize
just not putting food into the body for
those prolonged periods of time and
seeing how
the delayed gratification feels true
north
should be available in every city
this is critical right now it's in the
north bay
i believe in santa rosa up in california
in norcal and
true north should be available in la
and new york in chicago miami seattle
dallas houston atlanta
boston philadelphia d.c
should be available everywhere
across the world as well london hong
kong tokyo
berlin johannesburg
cairo rio de janeiro
and the reason why is because there's
so many people that don't know about the
benefits of the 10-day fast and to be
able to do that
in the state of also having medical
supervision
makes people feel more comfortable that
there's somebody there that's taking
their vitals
as they're undergoing the process that
there's another level of accountability
there as well with the hawthorne effect
with the observer as well which is great
and to drive down the price of true
north as well to make it
as zero barrier of entry to people as
possible
so you have this increase of sensory
acuity during fasting as well
the acuity of the census is increased by
fasting after 31 day abstinence from
food
lavonsin could see twice as far as he
did at the beginning of the fast
which is nuts sense of taste is more
acute and discriminating following the
fast than before the fast it's a reset
of your taste buds
it actually feels holy after not eating
for five days
to put the first bite of food in your
mouth it feels holy it feels divine
because you've reset the neurochemical
storms
there's an astonishing mental clarity of
prisoners in starvation
the fasting person sometimes sleeps no
more than three to four hours a day
that definitely has happened to me in my
prolonged fast where i'm just waking up
after four hours not even sleepy
anymore and i'm just like cool let's get
to the day
that was efficient fasting took off in
silicon valley because
of a competitive advantage for cognitive
edge
which is fascinating so literally
increasing your biological fitness to
the degree
of which fasting makes you more
productive and efficient at those
orchards of low-hanging fruit and then
your
biological fitness increases as well as
you gain more of those fruits and share
them with the civilization and procure
better mates
and all that and friends and success in
general
athletes training in the fasted state
growth hormone is high for athletes
after fasting 24 hours
then working out
and that's why the vast majority of
people when they have a
really important performance whether
it's athletic
or musical or if they're
doing a presentation or if they're doing
a test
that they will not eat
so right now i'm like
16 or more hours fasted maybe even
approaching 20 hours of being fasted
right now
and because of that i'm
much more
performing at a higher
level than if i also was in the process
of digesting food that i had just eaten
two hours ago
love this autophagy
self-eating this is probably
another one of the most critical along
with bhb
and bdnf is autophagy scientifically
is so critical this is your body's
molecular dejunking mechanism
intracellular digestion stem cells
reactivate and make new cells
there's programmed cell death apoptosis
of your old cell synalysis
kill cancer cells that depend heavily on
glucose
warburg effect cancer cells are more
vulnerable
in the fasting state
21 day water only fast removed stage 3
lymphoma cancer at true
north fasting is a scientific method of
ridding
the system of disease tissue and morbid
matter
tissues are lost in the inverse order of
their usefulness
fat and morbid tissue go first
autophagy also plays a housekeeping role
in removing misfolded or aggregated
proteins clearing damaged organelles
such as mitochondria
all animals when forced to go without
food produce some of the most marvelous
phenomena in the whole realm of biology
no more profound change in metabolism is
possible than that produced by
fasting most humans can understand
eating to get strong but it takes a long
time to educate them to
stop eating to get strong
autophagy is so mind-blowing you already
have the
organic house cleaning capacities that
are built into
your metabolic pathways that occur
during fasting
but we have to unsubscribe from the
cultural
dogma of eating three times a day
and recognizing to become strong
sometimes we actually have to
not eat for days at a time
i love this benefit as well vasodilation
fasting decreases blood pressure
non-pharmalog
pharmacologically induced
even light exercise or fasting
vasodilate
this is increasing blood flow to body
tissues that need it most
oxygenation healing vaso activity
example
is like your vasoconstriction when
fingers are exposed to cold to retain
heat
so that's why you have your extremities
your fingers your toes
that get really cold is because you have
a vassal constriction process that's
happening
that is then keeping the warmth in the
central
organs of the body and so
you have fasting that creates this
vasodilation
this opening up that then decreases the
blood pressure
that then allows the blood flow
to heal the portions of your body to
oxygenate those portions of your body
that need it
most that then enable the process of the
autophagy to actually happen
for the bdnf to actually happen
and so we need to
recognize that the vasodilation
especially for blood pressure and
metabolic syndrome is going to be really
critical here
because so many of the perverse
pharmaceutical
incentives are that we will
give you a pill that's going to cause
vasodilation
no no no
delay your gratification delay your
gratification stop
eating for a couple days and you will
notice you're gonna drop
five pounds you're going to
feel fantastic but you have to get over
the dogma and you have to get over the
instant gratification
another critical one addictions two to
four days into fasting
smokers don't feel like smoking
and it's another great proven value of
fasting and alcoholism
as well it's so fascinating how fasting
is even more successful at tackling
addictions just like entheogens are
really successful at tackling addictions
than any of the other perverse
incentives and dogmas that have been
peddled
for the last couple of decades just
treating the symptoms
instead of treating the root cause
every major spirituality has a fasting
tradition
jesus fasted 40 days pythagoras
had students fast 40 days before
entry to his school plato and aristotle
frequently
fasted 10 days communing with the
infinite this is what happens that
you're on your third day of fasting and
you're just
laying down in the sun and you're
recognizing
more and more your delayed gratification
you're recognizing how spiritually
pleasing that is
you're recognizing your monkey mind is
wandering less
that you're relaxing back into just
being aware
of being aware and that's what god
realization is
so you become more spiritually in tune
with the infinite as well
and not just being a contracted egoic
identity in the finite and so
beautiful that's why it's been used
spiritually by
all of the traditions across the planet
why do we call it the perennial wisdoms
of these mystic traditions because they
knew for millennia
and modernity is so polluted with
instant gratification and noise
it can't parse and find the signal and
that's what we do with this show
is we help communicate the signal
when you break the fast
the care that must be exercised in
breaking a fast is in proportion to the
length of the fast
and to the general condition of the
fasting individual
the approved plan is to break the fast
on liquid food
using for this purpose fruit juice or
tomato juice
or watermelon juice or vegetable broths
fruit juice
usually orange juice is used most often
and the gain and weight after a fast is
usually very rapid
so when you're breaking your fast that's
why it's called break
fast breakfast in the morning when you
break your fast
and you do it after two days three days
five days ten days
these prolonged fasts make sure your
refeeding
is very sensitive very subtle very
gentle
we have an evolutionary mismatch in
modernity
the pressure cooker is so strong to
awaken
in modernity from the perverse
incentives
the dopaminergics of information
foraging as well as salt oil sugar
we have stone age brains medieval
institutions and god-like technology
we went from one billion humans
to 8 billion humans we went from rural
to metropolises with this big gold rush
for the economy
we went from low salt oil sugar to now
everything is high fructose corn syrup
and oils
and salts we went from having no
information technology
to now 200 times a day checking our
phones
this is a big evolutionary mismatch in
modernity and it's fascinating to watch
that's why there's so many people that
are going on fasts
not only from food but fasts from
technology as well
because they want to regain their
sovereignty
they want to regain their ability as a
supreme authority that's able to
have self-discipline
that's not a slave to the
salt oil and sugar into social media
here's another way to look at it
gut microbes are 3 billion years old
whereas
agriculture is 10 000 years old that's
why you have
indian ayurvedic medicine which is 2 000
plus years old
where the teaching is
your stomach being about a third liquid
and having a third food so you have your
third
drinking some water filling it up then
you have a third of it as
food and then keeping a third of it as
empty
these wisdoms from the perennial
traditions
the first fifty percent of food actually
tastes the best anyway because your
taste receptors acclimate
you're training your stomach stretch
receptors to feel satiety you have to
feel
satiated
and we mentioned this earlier again it's
very perennial across the traditions
bigu means grain avoidance it's a common
medical cure in china
you fast to gain a glimpse into
immortality
hara hachi buu it's confusion in
japanese you eat until you're 80
full eight parts of a full stomach
sustain the man
and the other two sustain the doctor so
stop eating until you're a hundred plus
percent full
eat until you're like 75 full
delay your gratification blue zones love
blue zones
blue zones are pockets of the world that
have these
highest percentage of centenarians
people that live until they're over 100
years old and
analysis of what their most common
traits and habits
are and so in okinawa and japan the
elders there
they have a bmi of about 18 to 22
whereas the usa elders over 60
they have a bmi of 26 to 27 so we're
[ __ ] up
our health care system and costs and
okinawa has the world's highest
proportion of centenarians about
50 per 100 000. so 0.05
and there's your bmi chart down there
where you have
the normal range for okinawans
whereas the
usa elders are in the overweight class
reduce caloric intake 30 and live
30 longer but it's also of course
important which calories you're intaking
man lives on 25 of what he eats the
doctor lives on the other 75 percent
again these little aphorisms and little
wisdoms for you to take away
and recognizing that well maybe i should
eat just a smaller portion
of what i was even planning to eat
instead of having
the whole
massive steak and potatoes and
vegetables and all of that
maybe i'll eat a third of all of that
now and then i'll save the other third
of it for
tomorrow and then
maybe i'll share that the last third
with somebody else that comes over
tomorrow for lunch
or dinner
and to practice that process
because it's going to take time to
adjust to neuro adapt to that
and many people know this too also with
sweets
is that the more that you neuro adapt to
eating
sweets the more you're going to crave
them and the more that you stay
abstinent from eating sweets the more
your sweet tooth decreases as well
and this is a really important parable
the parable of the rich fool
luke 12 13. where
the biblical story is about wealthy
that have these abundant harvests and
that
don't know what to do with all the
excess and they build larger and larger
storage structures to be able to handle
it
and to just eat drink and be merry
rather than recognizing that
actually with the excess it's important
for us to
funnel that to meeting the basic needs
of other people worldwide
and then having that grow the pie for
everybody
and it's a hilarious feature of our
realities where food is one of the
greatest indulgences but restricting
food
prolongs your life it's fascinating
it's like both food is incredible
and we adore it and we want to eat it
three times a day
but fasting for three days actually
extends your life
so this is called the pleasure trap
sos triggers a dopamine cascade
makes food taste better addicts us and
systematically
makes us overeat food and sex
are the two highest reward functions
that's nuts and that's why
it's so neurochemically addicting
sick care pleasure trap pandemic
two-thirds of people in industrialized
society are overweight slash
obese hypertension
high blood pressure affects 50 million
in usa and 1 billion worldwide
and it's called the end-of-life conveyor
belt where there's the economic perverse
incentive
to keep people in the revolving door
of the healthcare industrial complex
rather than get them out through these
fasting techniques and through
naturopathy
metabolic syndrome this is obesity high
blood pressure and high blood sugar
triggers cardiovascular disease type 2
diabetes 25
of us adults have it we have to undo
our excess dietary excess is responsive
to fasting
again nothing in excess the delphic
maxim
here are all the things to un that undo
from fasting obesity cardiovascular
disease
high blood pressure type 2 diabetes
autoimmune diseases metabolic syndrome
cancers
and these are all the things that
fasting can also accomplish the removing
of these tumors and cancers
healing anemia healing lung disease
healing tuberculosis
healing diseased gums rejuvenating skin
decreasing oxidative and inflammatory
stress and disease
instead of the heart growing weak during
a fast it grows stronger every
hour as the load it has been carrying is
lessened
high blood pressure is invariably
lowered and this removes a heavy load
from the heart
beautiful fasting provides a rest for
the stomach
thus giving it an opportunity to repair
itself
digestion is improved the stomach
shrinks to its normal size
ulcers heal inflammation subsides
gastric qatar is eliminated and the
appetite becomes
normal the stomach intestines and colon
are given a complete
rest by the fast and are enabled to
repair
damaged structures he that takes
medicine
and neglects diet wastes the skill of
the physician
let thy fast be thy medicine
again he that takes the medicine and
neglects the diet wastes the skill of
the physician
let thy fast be thy medicine
the results are crazy people lose a
pound per day or more
from fasting 80 percent of type 2
diabetes can achieve
normalization without medication with
just fasting
a massive detoxification happens where
we free the body of its accumulated
toxins
fasting rapidly drains toxins when you
break down a fat biopsy you see these
hundreds of chemicals things like pcb
dioxin pesticide residues mercury
bpa is an endocrine disruptor and
catalyzes a whole suite of other issues
and when we pour boiling water into
plastic lined
cups it increases the bsa bpa
seeping by 55 times so bpa linings on
single-use coffee cup industry could be
causing a suite of downstream health
problems
the mainstream media msm not one word
about fasting corrupt as [ __ ]
for alcoholics you need to come up with
a strategy to not drink and you'll win
but for obesity we'll just decrease your
portion sizes
face palm obviously you have to fast
just like people fast with firm alcohol
or they fast from their addictions they
also have to fast from their addiction
of food
and big pharma wants to mimic fasting in
a pill so you can keep
pummeling salt oil sugar and then just
taking a pill
this is an analogy that came to me as
well is really interesting
the human dodo bird analogy because the
dodo bird
became the inability to fly
and because of how large it became
and similarly with humans consuming high
fructose corn syrup
and also having the information
technology foraging addictions
and no north star feedback loops so not
in pursuit of a noble transcendent aim
it makes the human dodo bird go extinct
in one century
so people like here pictured become
hyper glycemic
so have an excess of sugar in their
blood and hypofrontal
so they don't have enough prefrontal
cortex
executive functioning and delayed
gratification
and now we're going to also talk about
helio hygienics which means sunbathing
and we're also going to talk about
air bathing as well because these are
two critical components to
naturopathy that must be coupled with
fasting
and that also just must be added into
the daily life
on a preferably on a 30 minutes every
day
just bathing in the sun in the air which
i'll i'm about to do right after the
stream because the sun just came out and
she looks so beautiful
so sunlight exercises upon certain
organisms
of vitalizing influence which science
has not yet quite explained
life is a sun child
at canada of egypt zoroaster of persia
hippocrates of greece
each elevated the sun to the dignity of
a god and a force
pliny said that soul est
remordium maximum so the sun is the best
remedy
man was originally a nude animal at one
time or another the whole human race has
worshipped the sun as god the sun
feeds the mussels the best food and
medicine in the world
sunlight contains in addition to the
color rays
a number of other rays the vibrations of
which
are not perceptible to our ocular sense
and are therefore invisible
the invisible rays of the sun seem to be
the most beneficial to our bodies
photosynthesis is the manufacture of
carbohydrates out of carbon dioxide
and water in the chlorophyll containing
parts of plants exposed to sunlight
cancer is less prevalent in the sunny
regions
of the earth
the more a man lives in sunlight other
things being equal the more
vigorous will his brain be under sun
influence breathing becomes deeper and
slower
sleep sounder blood pressure is
diminished and urinary
excretion is increased ulcers
sores skin diseases etc heal more
rapidly under its influence
the skin itself is rejuvenated by such
bathing
sunshine aids in building good teeth
sunshine is an essential catalytic agent
in both
plant and animal life
it's so essential as a catalytic agent
we are sun
children we need to respect sunbathing
more
sun baths before and after childbirth
increase the mother's ability to nurse
her baby and improve the quality of the
milk
sun is an important aid in building and
maintaining health and
we should not wait until we become sick
to make use of it
every home should have a solarium
sunlight benefits the ailing human body
in the same manner that in
influences impoverished plant life in
both cases it increases the oxygen
carrying matter hemoglobin or
chlorophyll
every woman is very careful to put her
pot plants out into the sun
why not her children also
if man were always to go entirely naked
the bones would be less liable to
disease and distortion
normal unprotected skin can endure
50 minutes of sunbathing without burn
newspapers media tend to emphasize the
dangers of
sunbathing on one hand while
emphasizing the virtues of suntan
lotions on the other
perverse incentives sunbathing is
entirely different from the popular
practice of enjoying the fresh air
the bath is taken with all of the
clothing removed
care must be taken to not burn the body
too little rather than too much should
be the rule
blondes and red-haired people must be
more careful than brunettes and members
of the dark races
sunshine stimulates the growth of hair
it is a well-known fact that sunshine
accelerates the growth of hair
and more exposure of the head to its
influence
might easily reduce the number of
bald-headed people by preventing
baldness
begin the sun bath by exposing the
entire body six to ten minutes a day
and gradually increase the length of
time of exposure
until half an hour to an hour or more
even to three and four hours are
consumed
the best and healthiest rule in the sun
bath is constant movement
rest in the shade
animals seek the sunlight but avoid its
heat
this is to say they prefer to be in the
sun during the cool portions of the day
and seek the shade when it grows hot
little boxes in high rises have very
little place for fresh air
sunbathing green grass flowers and
animals
so now we'll talk about the air bath and
this is called the atmospheric
cure where you get the sun bath you get
the light bath you get the air bath
naturopathy should no longer be called
pseudoscience
nature bathing is scientifically proven
to decrease cortisol levels
naturism nudism is also critical
ancient greeks viewed nakedness as the
natural state
abrahamic religions viewed it as
shameful
and this is also likely where clothing
originated
from that idea of shame and also from
the need to block out the sun and to
stay warm about
a hundred thousand years ago as we
became self-aware
aware of our awareness
baths of water are good baths of air are
better and baths of sunlight are best
benjamin franklin was in the habit of
taking air bass each morning in his room
franklin particularly desired to divest
himself of all clothing when doing
mental work
air playing over the body may increase
metabolism 50
in 10 minutes which you totally feel
when you go
outside and you just begin spinning
around and dancing and just
feeling that air bath happening in the
sun bath
you totally feel like your entire
organism's metabolism has increased
you feel fantastic physiologically
as soon as people realize that sun and
air bass are more important than
water baths all of our cities will have
public sun parks
where the people may go and take their
sun and air baths
it is a good thing to train oneself to
resist an exaggerated dread of cold
no time is more convenient for the air
bath than immediately
upon arising in the morning while one
goes through his or her
daily exercises
so that's the end i definitely wanted to
touch on
sunbathing and air bathing which are
critical components to naturopathy in
general
and just getting into the process of
just going out and just bathing in the
sun for at least
five or ten minutes and just stretching
and having the air bath as well
and just treating that as something to
do every couple of hours
every single day because that's actually
what makes us feel a lot better
being here sedentary and using these
devices
it as not as pleasing to do
for several hours at a time as it is to
take a break
after just an hour or two and go and
take 10 15 minutes to stretch
and to exercise and to sunbathe and air
bathe
and then to come back for the hour or
two to complete
what you were doing and it just makes us
feel
so much better and
i'm really happy we were able to cover
those two topics
along with all of the perverse
incentives that exist
and how to upgrade to the next
generation of incentives
how to heal the all of these diseases
uh the metabolic syndrome and how we
actually have
our understanding of the pleasure trap
and how to
avoid the instant gratification to avoid
the evolutionary mismatch of modernity
to delay our gratification to understand
why spirituality has been pointing at
this for the longest time
to understand it at a scientific level
with vasodilation
with autophagy with the sensory acuity
increasing with the longevity movement
with bdnf
with bhb with ketosis
with ghrelin with all the different
styles of fasting that exists
to transition to the inclusive
stakeholding understanding how we got
here
the marshmallow experiment delaying our
gratification
how gluttony relates to idleness and
geoeconomics
dropping off fear understanding how
animals have been doing this
understanding how we've been doing this
for so long all of the physiological
rest and rejuvenation benefits of
fasting
again giving the organs a complete rest
stopping the intake of foods emptying
and rejuvenating the gi tract
promoting elimination of diseased tissue
and cellular components restoring useful
condition and function throughout the
body
and clearing and strengthening the mind
and increasing our fitness
organic house cleaning adore those three
words
remember those three words with fasting
organic
house cleaning and
therapeutic hygienic fasting and the two
that i would recommend investigating
herbert shelton and all of his synthetic
literature
on fasting and all his distillations
and alan goldhammer and true north as
well
he has a lot of great content online
i'm super happy we were able to do this
synthesis and distillation on fasting
it's one of the most important concepts
that synthesizes science and
spirituality
and that maximizes our well-being and
prosperity and that drives that
self-discipline towards the delayed
gratification which we have to
popularize and mainstream
so we'll be making a lot more content
around this as well
especially as we develop out these
larger scale documentaries
that really dive into these nuances and
even better stories with even better
animations
with even better ability to land the
concept of fasting in your heart and
trigger more people around the world to
awaken away from the perverse incentives
and towards the delayed gratification
and towards
the water only fast which maximizes so
much of our prosperity and well-being
that's all folks i adore you thank you
so much for tuning
in infinite love
and if it brought you value like the
video subscribe if you haven't
share the video with people that you
know this would make a profound
influence on
and if you want more badass content like
this
and beyond we have a lot of epic plants
here in la you can click the join button
below and join the members only
community and help
fuel the actualization of these
endeavors and get great perks along the
way
as well and
do it discipline yourself
delay your gratification and just
bathe in the incredible long-term health
benefits
that this gives you and get out into the
sun and air bathing
as well
naturopathy and the indigenous wisdoms
and these perennial wisdoms across the
spiritual traditions they have so
much insight that has been lost in the
noise of modernity
so to go back and fetch that and to
embed that
in our future is really critical
so again infinite love
thank you so much
and this is only the beginning of
incredible synthesis
and distillations of these most profound
concepts that we'll be leveraging to
awaken and enlighten civilization
to the future more abundant protocols
and infrastructures and architectures
that just maximize everyone's peace and
happiness
and everyone's fullest gift
actualization and potential
and god realization
as infinity expressing itself
adore you infinite love thank you
organic house cleaning